jean marie virapoullé j'ai 52 ans je
suis médecin je suis troisième vice
président du département déléguée à
l'action sociale coordination de
l'action sociale et à la prévention
santé
[Musique]
canton 5 saint-andré 2 c'est un canton
qui correspond à la ville de saint-andré
de tir de la ville je suis attaché
puisque j'ai été élu local adjoint et
j'ai occupé des fonctions importantes
dans ce canton j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
la confiance de la population puisque
c'est un mandat qui était renouvelé
aujourd'hui et je suis attaché parce que
c'est une ville où je suis né dans
laquelle je vis dans laquelle je
travaille à laquelle je suis attaché
aussi par rapport aux liens importants
que j'ai avec cette population donc je
suis particulièrement heureux d'avoir
obtenu la confiance des électrices et
des électeurs pour poursuivre et
amplifier l'action que j'ai déjà engagés
j'ai la lourde tâche et en même temps la
belle mission de m'occuper de l'action
sociale qui est le coeur de métier du
département et avec entre autres ce
grand plan de lutte contre la pauvreté
qui permet à l'état de nous donner des
financements nouveaux pour accompagner
les publics en situation de précarité et
les orienter vers une insertion
professionnelle
également j'ai aussi cette tâche de la
réforme des aides sociales pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que ces aides soient plus
efficiente plus adaptées plus réactive
et que plus rapide à obtenir de façon à
ce qu'on puisse lutter la plus le plus
activement possible efficacement
possible contre la pauvreté
je m'occupe également de la prévention
santé dans un contexte où la santé est à
la une de l'actualité avec notamment là
que 8,19 les grandes pandémies les
grandes maladies et dans un contexte où
la réunion est particulièrement touchée
par le diabète et maladies
cardiovasculaires on est aussi les
problèmes des addictions nous avons
lancé un grand plan addiction en
partenariat avec les différents référent
de le chu le dr mété et les autres
partenaires ce grand plan addiction va
se poursuivre et on va occuper tous les
champs de la prévention santé et re
renforcer retisser nos liens avec tous
les partenaires notamment les
partenaires associatifs pour renforcer
la prévention santé
mais n'est pas devant c'est un acte
locale un acteur du quotidien on peut
les aider en améliorant leur quotidien
puisque nous intervenons dans
l'aménagement le développement des
quartiers on peut les aider par cet
accompagnement social également qu'ils
soient plus proches d'eux en allant vers
eux en connaissant réellement leurs
besoins et en nous adaptant besoin pour
que coller au mieux à la réalité et leur
apporter un mieux-être